thank you so much an emotional Maren
Morris accepting the Country Music Award
for album of the year the country star
used her speech to pay tribute to late
record producer Busby who died in
September he it really remiss if I
didn't mention a a huge facet of why
this album sounds the way it does and
that's our friend Busby Marin also
performed her hit girl weeks after
announcing she's expecting a baby boy
the mama to be told
et why this CMAs will be one to remember
when he looks back at this footage of me
performing on this particular award show
it's gonna be this thing where he was in
there Marin's win capped off a night
celebrating women in country music this
show began with a mega medley full of
famous faces including legends like
Dolly Parton Reba McEntire and Carrie
Underwood
[Music]
[Applause]
plus some fresh faces including Mayor
Morris's supergroup the high women
[Music]
and Martina McBride
and the memorable performances didn't
stop there
Miranda Lambert took the stage to sing
her new hit and Reba had the crowd on
their feet singing fancy
she told et what it meant to celebrate
female songwriters a women in country
music are strong they're powerful they
love to sing songs that tell stories
because it's it's stories that people
can relate to
Kelsea Ballerini delivered this
stripped-down performance of homecoming
queen even the home come and clean
Christ
and dished on her new music I'm really
proud of it it's the first album that
I've not only written everything but
I've also co-produce so I'm like really
invested in it the Knights hosting
duties were also covered by the ladies
Carrie Underwood hosted for the 12th
consecutive year but this time she had
to guest co-host Reba and Dolly three
women hosting the CMAs your lucky night
meanwhile the night's biggest honor
Entertainer of the Year went to Garth
Brooks the seventh time he's taken home
the award and the fact that it came on
the tribute to the women's night being
married to one the greatest female
singers ever and being the father of
three daughters love this show this is
very special
like Shelton took home the award for
single of the year for God's Country and
we found him backstage celebrating when
hear you've got a drink in your cup
already doing it I'm all ready to
celebrate yeah I figured if I end up
doing these interviews after an awards
ceremony that must mean something good
happen some of the night's biggest
performances came from pop stars pink
joined Chris Stapleton to sing love me
anyway
[Music]
et spoke with the singer who didn't hold
back praising Stapleton
he's my person I think he's my favorite
voice today in music truly I mean he's
the most amazing songwriter then there
was Halsey who joined Lady Antebellum on
stage for a pop country mashup
and speaking of mashups et caught up
with winners lil nas ex and Billy Ray
Cyrus who took home the CMA for musical
event of the year for old country road
and it sounds like they may have another
collab in the works I think you two
should do a remix of achy-breaky heart
I've been getting that a lot you know
I'm down I'm down but we want to make
something original I think makes you
guys are still down to work together and
keep it going I love this guy Manny he's
a good guy he's a good man and also he
he's a genius
[Music]